ac on peut envisager qu'après une banque
de sperme et rock band à la congélation
d'ovocytes
un sujet qui émergent dans les années 80
congeler des spermatozoïdes est déjà
autorisé alors pourquoi pas des ovules
et cette technique de congélation ne
sera mise au point qu'au début des
années 2000
la grande bretagne est alors l'un des
premiers pays européens à autoriser la
congélation d'ovocytes pour convenances
personnelles elles peuvent faire
congeler leurs jeux quand elles ont à
peu près 30 ans et que l'heure ce sont
de bonne qualité et les garder
et quand elles sont enfin prêtes à être
enceintes si leurs ovules sont de moins
bonne qualité elles peuvent revenir et
utiliser les congeler quelques années
plus tôt l'espagne l'italie ou la
belgique autorise aussi cette pratique
mais en france la congélation d'ovocytes
pour une grossesse plus tardive soulève
des questions éthiques
pour le professeur israël nisand cette
technique est pourtant révolutionnaire
je crois qu'on ne peut pas interdire la
congélation d'ovocytes parce qu'une
femme qui un cancer à l'âge de 16 ans et
qui va subir des traitements qui la
rendront stérile avec cette technique
peut espérer avoir un enfant alors
qu'elle n'a pas encore rencontré son
compagnon
je crois que c'est véritablement un
progrès
cette année là en 2010 la congélation
d'ovocytes est toujours strictement
interdite en france mais au nom de la
science le professeur frydman contourne
la loi dans son service des jumeaux
naissent après l'implantation d'ovocytes
congelés
ça ouvre la porte à la création d'une
banque d'ovules équivalent de la banque
de sperme pour le don d'ovocytes et
essayer de tarir ce tourisme médical qui
se fait dans les pires conditions
entière l'année suivante en 2011 la
révision de la loi bioéthique autorise
finalement la congélation d'ovocytes en
france mais uniquement pour les couples
infertiles et les femmes atteintes d'une
maladie mettant en péril leur fécondité
alors pour toutes celles qui veulent
simplement congeler leurs ovules pour
une grossesse plus tardive une seule
solution aller à l'étranger assez lourd
comme démarche et surtout quand on est
seule en fait on jean ce sens que dans
l'illégalité on sent coupable côté de
quelque chose
face à cette évasion obstétricales le
collège des gynécologues obstétriciens
ont fait des recommandations au comité
d'éthique en 2012 la congélation
d'ovocytes doit être accessible à toutes
les femmes pour leur confort personnel
et pas seulement pour des raisons
médicales et un grand nombre de femmes
qui avancent en âge qui n'ont pas encore
eu les enfants qu'elles désirent et qui
lorsqu'elle se décide parce que la ville
l'a rendu possible possible pour elle de
mettre en route une grossesse n'y arrive
pas et donc le fait d'avoir mis en
réserve aussi tulle et permettrait
d'avoir une fécondité quasi normal
l'élargissement de la congélation
d'ovocytes fait partie des thèmes
majeurs de la révision de la loi
bioéthique
or raisons médicales elle pourrait être
ouverte à toutes les femmes dans une
certaine
limite d'âge
[Musique]